des grilles cadenassées l'accès au
palais de justice est impossible ce
mercredi matin les avocats du barreau de
nevers sont en grève générale ils
dénoncent une réforme de la justice qui
leur inspire beaucoup des craintes et
bien qu'on fasse des économies sur tout
et que il ya au moins deux magistrats à
l'avenir - d'avocats forcément alors je
vous parle à long terme mais c'est
effectivement le risque puisque le but
ultime c'est les excès sont les
économies on se retrouve face à une
réforme qui va éloigner la justice des
justiciables faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui des justiciables doivent
se faire défendre à dijon à orléans à
bourges et nevers des salles d'audience
inhabituellement vide c'est le but de
cette journée justice morte
les personnes concernées par les
affaires prévu aujourd'hui sont restés
bloqués à l'extérieur
si vous permettez madame présidente
puisque nous avons nous sommes mis
devant les grilles du palais pour
empêcher les justiciables aujourd'hui
effectivement d'avoir accès au palais de
justice tous les dossiers sont donc
renvoyer les personnes citées à
comparaître devront être reconvoqués les
conséquences sont très simple c'est à
dire c'est une des organisations c'est
ce que nous cherchons du fonctionnement
de la justice est à dire un renvoi
systématique de tous les dossiers c'est
malheureusement mais sait on vit dans un
pays où pour se faire entendre il faut
arriver des actions un peu plus extrême
surpopulation extrême
le mouvement devrait être reconduit les
avocats espèrent ainsi que la grogne des
petits tribunaux remontera jusqu'à la
ministre de la justice
la même